in between takes Gina you said something
interesting you've got to know when
you're losing this the room hypothetical
room how do you know you can you know
when somebody I mean you're gonna
there's always exceptions where somebody
will look incredibly interested in then
you know you're from your age in such a
pass you know that there's exceptions
but by and large you know these people
are is interested in finding a great
movie as you are in delivering it you
know and so they you know you believe
you have this great idea they want you
know they want to believe that you have
this great idea so at the cause it helps
their career and you know people their
jobs or is um vulnerable as ours you
know we're all interlocked dependency
and when they see that there's no way
that they're going to be able to sell
this thing to their boss their attention
trips you know you see him check and you
know their phone you see a mom looking
at their message slips you see them
checking the other you know their
colleagues you just you know like
anything I mean any good no it's like
being on a date you know when the date
is like not chicken you know and then
you just know now that and I've never
been surprised I've never had ever
aren't you know I don't have my pictures
I've gone to but plenty I've it's never
been like oh that tanked where you then
here no they loved it you know if they
don't you know it's like you know when
you will if you own a house so you know
your realtor says or don't act like you
like it you know but it's not like that
you know if the person likes it they
wanna they want to engage you right away
they want to put their vision and if
they're a good executive they improve it
you know and you can tell if they like
it now whether I've had executive sync
god I love this there's nowhere I could
sell it you know um but when you're in
the middle of a pitch you know and I
always say look I'll tell you the
concept and the arena and if you like it
I'll tell you the scene
because if they don't like the concept
like if they don't want to do a movie
you know about grasshoppers in Alaska
why bother telling them the scenes and
they're grateful for that because these
people are busy you know they'll go no I
don't want to do another snow movie you
know next you know and because they are
you know a lot of people go in there and
they're afraid of them and there's
nothing to be afraid of I'm yeah they
they decide whether it's rare that
they're the ones that say yes or no
because it's always a committee and
blahblah but you know they need you as
much as you need them and that's what
the timid writer has to realize that
they need ideas and you know and then
it's just a question of you know is that
one for them and that's why it's hard
for writers that don't know how to pitch
I mean you know not everybody's a
salesperson and but you have to be in
those rooms because unless you are an
already established brilliant writer
that they know you'll deliver you know
they don't know that if you if you're
there just meeting you and it's a raw
pitch
you